hallo zusammen wir machen heute ein
Mittagessen und wir achten auf unser
Budget wir müssen sparen es ist wird
alles teurer das weiß ich aber ich zeige
euch dass ihr auch euer Mittagessen für
Achtung unter 2 € pro Person kochen
können und zwar ein richtig leckeres
[Musik]
wir machen indisches Butter chicken
eigentlich wie das Original Butter
chicken natürlich dann auch mit
Cashewkernen gemacht das sind ja auch
nicht gerade günstig frische Tomaten etc
und ganz vielen exotischen Gewürzen ich
zeige euch heute eine einfache Variante
und wie gesagt unter zwei Euro und wenn
es genau wissen möchtet kostet eine
Portion 1,59 € und es ist extrem lecker
geht einfach und super schnell also
lasst uns direkt loslassen hallo lasst
uns direkt loslegen also beim Fleisch
kann man jetzt nicht so die Abstriche
machen ich finde das ist jetzt eine
Zutat da sollte man schon auf die gute
Qualität achten ihr könnt ja aber auch
im Supermarkt halt statt zum abgepackten
Fleisch auch an die Theke gehen oder
generell also ich gehe mal zum Metzger
meines Vertrauens so mache ich das oder
ihr könnt auch bei dem Gericht um da ein
bisschen Kosten zu sparen auch mal ein
bisschen weniger Fleisch nehmen und
dafür halt mehr von der Soße oder ihr
jubelt ein bisschen was an Gemüse unter
das würde dann auch quasi als ein
bisschen was an Fleisch Ersatz
durchgehen so Hackfleisch habe ich jetzt
sauber gemacht und schneide das in
mundgerechte Stücke dann gebe ich das in
die Schüssel und dann kommt die Marinade
[Musik]
beim Fleisch übrigens noch ein Tipp
schneidet immer gegen die Faser und
nicht mit der Faser dann wird es nicht
trocken das sind jetzt die mundgerechten
Stücke und die Marinade besteht aus
Naturjoghurt nimm den 3,5 prozentigen
habe ich einfach immer im Kühlschrank
ihr könnt auch den 10%igen nehmen wenn
ihr den fettarm verwendet dann könnte es
zu wässrig werden also das Fett gibt ja
auch Geschmack ab so dann einmal gut
verrühren und an Gewürzen brauchen wir
auch nicht viel wir haben hier einmal
Kreuzkümmel dann habe ich ganz klassisch
Paprika edelsüß und Garam Masala das ist
eine Gewürzmischung die ist auch sehr
sehr typisch für die indische Küche und
natürlich die Klassiker Salz und Pfeffer
das ganze dann zugedeckt 30 Minuten lang
ziehen lassen und dann machen wir in der
Zwischenzeit weiter mit dem Reis
[Musik]
so für den Reis einfach den Basmati
Langkornreis so lange unter ganz
normalem kalten oder lauwarmwasser
ausspülen bis unten das Wasser relativ
klar wieder rauskommt also ganz glasklar
wird nicht rauskommen aber wir wollen
die Stärke ein bisschen raus spülen und
dann klebt der Reis auch nicht mehr den
gebe ich jetzt hier mit Wasser in meinen
Topf und da kommt auch Salz mit dazu und
sobald das Wasser anfängt zu blubbern
runterschalten auf Stufe 2 oder 3 von 9
ich nehme immer Stufe 3 von 9 weil ich
habe sehr dickwandige Töpfe und da
braucht es einfach noch eine Stufe
wärmer so das Salz dazu gut verrühren
und dann den Deckel drauf und den Reis
circa 20 bis 23 Minuten garen lassen und
ich werde in der Zwischenzeit schon mal
meine zwiebeln fein hacken und mache
mich dann ins Wasser schicken
[Musik]
also ich schieb den Reis mal auf die
andere Herdplatte damit ihr mich auch
noch sehen könnt und jetzt erhitze ich
einmal meine Pfanne denn jetzt geht es
ans eingemacht ich habe übrigens auch
ein Original Butter chicken Rezept auf
meinem Kanal online da kommen wir dann
auch Cashewkerne rein und frische
Tomaten etc das kann ich euch gerne in
die Infobox verlinken falls ihr darauf
mal Lust habt heute geht es ja darum
einfach Kosten zu sparen und trotzdem
ein leckeres Butter chicken zu kochen
also wenn ihr jetzt schreibt der Film
aber Cashewkerne und dieses und jenes
dann also das ist halt dann soll ich
sagen das ist jetzt nicht Ziel das
Original zu machen das werden wir so
auch gar nicht schaffen jetzt gebe ich
hier schon mal ein bisschen
auf der Hamza an kurze Unterbrechung so
werbeunterbringt Werbung unterbrechen
die kurze Unterbrechung ist zu Ende
jetzt kommt einmal unser also ich nehme
jetzt Kokosfett ihr könnt auch Öl eurer
Wahl nehmen Moment sind die Ölpreise
sehr gestiegen also es geht eigentlich
Rapsöl Sonnenblumenöl würde gehen ich
nehme jetzt das desodor Kokosfett das
nehme ich eigentlich immer das habe ich
auch immer da aber da könnt ihr einfach
Öl eurer Wahl nehmen was ich auch gut
erhitzen lässt und da gebe ich jetzt
einmal das marinierte Hähnchen mit rein
und brate das scharf von allen Seiten an
und das ganze dauert wirklich nur 3
Minuten maximum also wir wollen das
jetzt nicht komplett durch braten und
trocken braten anschließend nehmen wir
es auch noch mal raus
[Musik]
das Hähnchen haben wir rausgenommen und
anschließend geben wir die fein
gehackten Zwiebeln mit rein da reicht
auch der restsud ich habe mir generell
dabei sehr viel zu drin habe ich mir
aufbewahrt und da steckt jetzt der ganze
Geschmack drin und das habe ich mir
einfach aufgebaut das kommt später noch
mit dazu achtet darauf dass sie jetzt
nicht zu viel nachölt weil am Ende habt
ihr so eine Fettschicht oben schwimmen
und das ist dann meistens nicht so
lecker mir hat jetzt einfach noch ein
bisschen was vom Sud gereicht das ist da
ist auch Fett drin und jetzt dünstet
gerade so ein bisschen Zwiebeln mit
Knoblauch und die Gewürze könnt ihr
jetzt darin auch noch rösten jetzt habt
ihr ja quasi die ganzen Röster rum wenn
ihr da noch mal unser Trio mit dazu gibt
also ein bisschen Cumin dann
Paprikapulver edelsüß und Garam Masala
das ganze wie gesagt 2 Minuten lang
rösten lassen und dann löschen wir das
Ganze ab mit passierten Tomaten
[Musik]
die passierten Tomaten lassen wir jetzt
8 bis 9 Minuten richtig schön
einreduzieren ich habe Stufe 6 von 9 es
darf nämlich ganz leicht köcheln und
jetzt ist es einfach noch wie so eine
Art
Tomatenpaste also ist schon sehr sehr
fest geworden und da geben wir jetzt
noch etwas Sahne und natürlich Butter
mit dazu und den Rest von unserem so da
ist ja wie gesagt auch noch der ganze
Geschmack drin das dürft ihr nicht
verschwenden und dann kommt einfach nur
noch unser Hähnchen zurück das ganze
wird noch mal schön erwärmt eventuell
zwei bis drei Minuten lang einreduziert
und dann ist es eigentlich auch schon
fertig ah noch mal eine kurze Sache zum
Nachwürzen natürlich noch mal mit Salz
und Pfeffer abschmecken und wenn ihr
mögt könnt ihr auch noch ein bisschen so
eine so einen halben Teelöffel Zucker
mit dazugeben weil das immer gut zur
Tomatensoße passt
[Musik]
[Applaus]
so das leckere Butter chicken ist jetzt
fertig wie gesagt das Hähnchen nicht zu
lange kochen am Ende wirklich nur noch
wenn ihr mögt ein reduzieren lassen es
sei denn ihr seid mit der Sämigkeit
zufrieden das ganze hier was hier steht
kostet ca 6,40 Euro und reicht für vier
Personen ich habe es hier ein bisschen
gut gemeint jetzt muss ich aufpassen so
und jetzt probiere ich mal und ich finde
es ging halt auch wirklich super schnell
und eigentlich hat man so die meisten
Zutaten ja auch zu Hause die Gewürze
müsst ihr euch bestimmt nicht extra
kaufen eventuell das Fleisch natürlich
frisch dazu holen aber Reis und Kohl man
hat ja eigentlich alles daheim ich teste
mal traumhaft
traumhaft also die Gewürze sind on point
ich würde nicht also ich vermisse gar
nicht ich liebe auch das Original Butter
chicken da ist die Konsistenz natürlich
leicht anders heißt nicht dass die
Konsistenz hier schlechter ist es nur
super sämige sehr intensive Soße und die
Gewürze einfach das Garam Masala das
kommt so gut durch Hähnchen ist zart
also für 1 € 59 oder 1,60 € pro Person
gönnt euch das ich weiß nicht ob ihr
jetzt
öfter solche Rezepte von mir sehen
möchte das könnt ihr mir gerne unten in
die Kommentare schreiben wollt ihr dass
ich wieder mal solche Vergleiche mache
ich denke wenn ich es online bestellt
hätte wäre ich letztens habe ich sogar
noch im inner bestellt pro Person 12,90
€ ungefähr und jetzt das im Vergleich
dazu ist schon extrem klar sollte man
auch die lokale unterstützen aber auch
ab und zu mal selber kochen und so ein
bisschen aus Budget achten also lasst
mir einen Kommentar da und dann sehen
wir uns auch beim nächsten Rezept
tschüss eure Kiki
[Musik]